Thanks so this is joint work with Lila
fonts yo Donna's Kennedy's in Metro
Dahlia who are with me at DF at
university by needle in Paris and also a
row Jane at National University of
Singapore and jelly me at all in
Brussels so in this talk we're going to
consider the question about whether
information complexity is equal to
communication complexity so you've heard
a talk about this yesterday and maybe
you're wondering why I'm standing here
since the problem has been solved so
we'll get to that in a moment so in
communication complexity the setting is
the following we have two players who
each have part of the input and they
want to solve some function or some
problems it depends on both of the
inputs and we're going to define
communication complexity is this
smallest amount of information that they
have to exchange in the worst case input
in order to solve this with some error
probability which might be up to an
epsilon fraction so in the standard
model model of communication complexity
one would consider correctness to be
required for all the inputs X Y so at
for every X Y you should have
correctness at least 1 minus epsilon
however you might also consider what
happens if you have a prior distribution
on the inputs so if you have an interest
rebutia on the inputs maybe some of the
inputs are not so frequent and you might
allow for them to have a little bit more
than epsilon error just as long as on
average over the distribution the the
probability of having an error is
bounded by epsilon so I just want to
point out that for this the purpose of
this talk we're just going to be talking
about boolean functions and we're also
going to allow shared randomness between
the players for free so how's theorem
the min-max theorem that probably
everybody is very familiar with says
that the communication complexity is
equal to taking the worst distribution
of the inputs and looking at the
distributional complexity for that fixed
worst-case distribution
somebody a friend of mine sent me this
cartoon after hearing about what I was
working on this is a non-specialist who
thought this was very funny so she says
there she says there there's some
conversations that bear a lot more bits
of information than they actually
communicate as in this case and this is
the question of whether you know can you
compress conversations so that each bit
that you speak actually bears
information so we need to measure what
we mean by information in the
conversation and we'll use internal
information complexity so you can define
it with respect to a prior distribution
mule on the inputs and what you're going
to be looking at informally is how much
information how much information does
Bob learn about Alice's input given the
transcript of the conversation that took
place plus the amount of information
that Alice learn so Alice knows X and
she wants to know we want to know how
much information she learns about Bob's
input given the chance of the transcript
of the conversation that took place and
if you want to talk about information
complexity in a non distributional sense
so you want a male average weight we
were take the worst possible
distribution then you would take again
the max over mu maybe this is the super
overview of the information complexity
with respect to a specific distribution
now it's a big open question whether
information reflects it e is equal to
communication complexity and again you
might be asking didn't we just solve
this yesterday but first why are we
interested in this question so if we
gave a positive answer I mean there's
many motivations one of them is just at
the theoretical motivation it's kind of
nice to know if you can do compression
in the interactive setting so without
errors for this particular case but also
a nice thing about information
complexity is that it has direct some
property it means if you have k
instances of a problem then it was great
it's going to require at least
k times the amount of community of the
amount of information in order to solve
one instance in order to solve the K
instances so we would like for this to
be true for communication complexity at
the moment if you have a function and
you want to show such a property then
you have to either prove a lower bound
on information complexity and show that
it's tight and then you get this direct
some property or you just have to work
very hard to get it ad-hoc using ad hoc
methods and if we had this theorem then
we would just get it for free for all
communication complexity so this talk is
about how could we go about proving or
disproving this conjecture about
information to lexi versus communication
complexity and imagine you would like to
show that communication complexity is in
fact at most the information flexy so
you can compress to the information
content then you would need to have all
right unless somebody comes up with a
with a more circuitous way of doing it
you would have to come up with a way to
compress any protocol to its information
complexity so take a communication
protocol and you you would want to be
able to change this protocol in such a
way that you don't have any wasteful
bits of communication that are not
convenient for any information on the
other hand if you'd like to separate
them then you'd like to find a function
or a task in the more general setting
ideally a total boolean function if you
could where you could show that the
information complexity is very small by
giving protocol and analyzing it and on
the other hand you'd have to show that
the communication complexity is very
high and for this you need strong lower
bound techniques so at the moment the
best result is the one that I've put on
the bottom of the slide so why are we
still here after yesterday's talk so
what we saw yesterday is an exponential
gap between information communication
for a fixed distribution mu so the
distribution is tailored very delicately
in order to get the information
complexity beat to be low how how
important is this distribution and how
fragile is the result to the specific
district
ocean well we're that's the question
that we wanted to ask is the technique
that they used sufficient to prove a
separation in the non distributional
case so let's just take a look at the
quantifiers and the directions of the
inequalities here what we would like to
show is a separation so one possible
answer that we would like to be acted go
after is we want to know if the
information complexity is bound is less
than the communication complexity for
any function for the specific function f
which is the same as saying that for the
worst mu the information complexity is
less than the communication complexity
for the worst miu now notice that these
different maximums can be attained for
different distributions mu right so what
could happen well here the communication
complexity can only go up so this part
can only become worse in terms I mean
the separation can only become worse but
the problem is here if you take a
different distribution new the
information complexity might jump up and
well let's see what happens
so again I'm coming back to if you
wanted to give a separation you need a
strong communication complexity lower
bound it's a jungle out there there's a
tremendous number of different
communication complexity lower bound
techniques that have been developed
developed over the years most of you are
probably familiar with a discrepancy
bound or the rectangle bound also called
the corruption bound but in recent years
there's been many other methods that
have been developed to prove that
communication complexity problems are
hard some recent developments there is a
proxy to approximate positive rank which
was recently shown for boolean functions
so again I'm being a little casual here
with this this picture one has to be a
little bit specific about these small
details like whether the function is a
boolean function a total boolean
function so some of these results only
hold for total boolean functions so the
arrows mean that for example here that
the partition bound is a greater than or
equal to the relaxed partition bound for
any function so actually here I'm
cheating a little bit because the part
the partition bound is scaled
exponentially bigger than the
communication complexity but what it
means is that for any function f here
for example the communication complexity
is at least as large as the information
complexity up to constant multiplied
with multiplicative factors ok so let's
just go through some of this these the
trees in this jungle so we've got the oh
and also I should mention that the
mapping out of this forest was initiated
or not entirely but a lot of the work
was done by Jane and clock in a paper in
2010 where they gave linear programs for
many of these lower bound techniques and
then compared them when para by two by
two so we get this kind of a hierarchy
so this is the rectangle bound the
smooth rectangle bound the discrepancy
the smooth discrepancy which is
equivalent to get the gamma 2 norm based
method
we have the partition bound which is a
lower bound on communication complexity
and then in 2012 with some co-authors we
showed that the relax 8 a modification a
slight modification of the partition
bound was actually a lower bound on the
information complexity which meant that
if you want to separate information from
communication none of these techniques
are going to are going to do the job for
you because the these will always give
you not just a lower bound on the
communication complexity but also on the
information complexity so if we want it
to or sorry at the moment so well I'll
get back to that a little bit later if I
have time at the end of the talk but at
the moment it seems like only the
partition bound is a candidate
unfortunately the partition bound we
don't really know how to use it there's
kind of a trade-off that goes on here
like we good why don't we just always
use a partition bound to prove lower
bounds it's because it's kind of tough
to manage you have to to fine-tune a lot
of variables and you have to you know
you have to find the correct way to get
this to be large whereas you know we
have a better intuition for the
discrepancy and the rectangle balance
and we're able to actually prove lower
bounds using those techniques but
computing the partition bound okay it is
a linear program but but most of us
would like a solution that works for any
any input length and so it's it's less
tractable so in this in this talk that
we saw yesterday they proposed a new
method which is called the relative
discrepancy and they show that for a
fixed distribution you can get a
separation here so the relative
discrepancy is going to be is going to
it gives a lower bound on the
communication complexity so the relative
discrepancy is large for this function
and for this distribution and the
information complexity for this for this
function in this distribution is small
this is what they should they had to
have an exponential gap there ok so but
in this picture which is more like a non
distributional picture I'd like to see
where this relative discrepancy sits
so that's going to be the first part of
the talk is we're going to try to see
where the relative describes the sits
with respect to the other just in the
non distributional setting and then for
me what gets where it gets maybe a
little technical but but a lot more
interesting in terms of you know what
what are these methods doing and how do
they compare to one another and maybe it
gives us an idea of where the the crux
of the problem lies in proving this
information complexity versus
communication complexity is exactly
where relative discrepancy sits relative
to the distribution of all of these
lower bounds so for example the
partition bound and the relaxed
partition bound I mean the partition
bound in Jane and cokes papers is given
in a non distributional fashion but you
can give a distributional analogue of it
relax partition so this upper bound
holds also relative to fix distributions
mu so so what's interesting for me is
what happens in this more fine-grain
setting where the distributions are
fixed just a question of the terminology
when you say that this Tribunal version
distributional means fixed for spurs so
distributional means for fixed
distribution non distributional means
the worst case distribution yeah
any questions
so well this gives it away so what we
show in this paper is that the relative
discrepancy when you're not when you're
not sick singh the distribution in fact
sits below the information complexity
and we show that by showing that it sits
below the relaxed partition bound so the
relaxed partition bound will always give
you at least as strong abound as the
relaxed discrepancy and the information
complexity gives you at least as strong
is at least as large as the relative as
the relaxed partition map so I still
haven't told you what these things mean
so let's maybe go into it now for a few
moments basically at this point I've
conveyed the message that I wanted to
convey like the the main the big picture
and I don't want to go into the
technical details but I would like to
try to give you some intuition about
what these methods are doing how to use
them and and what they're measuring so
maybe the authors in this room can can
tell me if they agree with my my
intuition about the relative discrepancy
so you're probably familiar with the
discrepancy method for communication
complexity lower bounds basically what
you're saying is you have a
communication protocol it breaks down
your inputs into rectangles and you
assign to each rectangle just one output
and relative discrepant sits so
discrepancy says if you if your
rectangles are large enough then they're
going to have high discrepancy meaning
that it's going to have roughly half
0answers and half one answer like the
correct answer is going to be divided
about half and half in every large
enough rectangle now this is what this
is representing this picture here so we
have a communication rectangle so this
is at the end of your protocol you're
going to out just give one answer for
this these inputs for of Alice and these
inputs of Bob and what you want to argue
is that for every large enough rectangle
the proportion of correct answer is
z equals zero should be about half which
means that if your protocol is going to
be correct the rectangles are going to
have to be small otherwise you're going
to have too much error okay so what does
the relative discrepancy do relative to
discrepancy is that it allows you to
account for the fact that in maybe so
the size of the rectangle is measured
according to your distribution mu and
perhaps so I think pregnant for example
11 case where you would want to to move
away from discrepancy and go towards
relative discrepancy is that you have
lots of different sizes of rectangles
and you might want to rescale them so
they're all similar size for example so
here in the discrepancy would not be
high enough in this rectangle so I'm
going to to rescale a little bit this
the size of the rectangle but not
rescale the size of the zero part of the
rectangle and then then this would still
have you know the desired amount of
discrepancy so it gives you a little bit
more wiggle space to establish the
discrepancy if your function is not
exactly as well behaved as you'd like
now let's move on to the partition bound
and the relaxed partition bound Raul is
not in the room so he might he has
probably a different intuition for what
this partition bound is measuring but my
personal intuition is an operational
intuition let's let's see how it goes so
we want to show that it's hard to
compute a function with a small amount
of communication so assume we do have a
protocol which which does compute it
with see bits of communication and it
computes it epsilon correctly so this is
the non distributional version of the
partition bound then I claim that there
has to be a communication protocol that
doesn't communicate so zero
communication protocol it's going to
make a lot of mistakes right if I remove
entirely the communication something has
to give I can't be correct by removing
the communication but what am I going to
pay for this removal of the
communication I'm going to allow the
players to say sorry I'm not able to
give an answer in this case and the
probability with which they're able to
give an answer is going to be related to
the communication complexity in the
following way so just briefly how would
we sketch such a proof so we have start
with a communication protocol and then
remove the communication entirely so
what can they do I mean they there's not
communicating anymore how can they
possibly solve the problem but they have
access to shared randomness so what
might we suggest so that with some small
probability they're actually able to
solve the problem let's guess the
transcript of the conversation now
locally each of the players can look at
this guest transcript and decide whether
they agree with it or not and if they
don't agree with this this random guess
then they just say sorry just throw up
their hands and despair and saying I'll
can't can't play but with probability 1
over the number of possible transcripts
that might have taken place they are
going to answer and they are going to be
able to follow the protocol I they're
able to output according to the protocol
so what is the partition bound measuring
well it's measuring the best efficiency
that you can achieve for any zero
communication protocol and we know that
you can achieve one over two to the see
if you have a seebut communication
protocol but there might be there might
be other right so this is not measuring
communication complexity it's measuring
something a little bit weaker there's a
very important constraint here is that
this what i call this efficiency the
rate at which you actually answer
something this has to be equal for every
X Y and it turns out that this is a very
important constraint this equality of
aborting and the difference between the
partition bound in the relaxed partition
bound is that you relax this condition
of having to abort at the same rate for
every X Y and this seems like a like why
would this matter well it matters
because if you take the relaxed
partition bound it's a it's a it's a
lower bound on information complexity
and if you require that the abort rate
be constant then well now we know that
it's not it cannot be a lower bound on
information complexity for some
functions because we have a
counterexample with a bursting noise
function could use soo ok i'm happy to
say that again what we don't get this
how does the role of being able to bear
the award rate so that that's in when we
proved that the information complexity
is bounded below by the relaxed
partition bound we're able to prove that
there are zero communication protocols
that abort at almost a constant rate but
we're not able to show that we can get a
zero communication protocol that aborts
at a constant rate where the rate
instead of being related to the
communication is related to the
information complexity and just that
that seems to that's where it breaks
down is in this this constants or non
constants of the import grade you have
to do with the fact that information is
an average case that's what I think yeah
that's that's my feeling is that there's
an average thing going on yeah
so if you want to prove a lower bound
using the partition bound what do you do
well if you want to give an upper bound
on the partition bound which is not
really what you want to do usually want
to prove a lower bound on the partition
bound if you want to prove an upper
bound it's easy because you just have to
give just provide me with an efficient
zero communication protocol analyze the
efficiency show that it's constant and
then you're done you have an upper bound
on the fish on the partition found but
if you want to give a lower bound then
you you have a for all statement you
have to show that any zero communication
protocol requires a high abort rate and
this is much more difficult so we tend
to look at the dual because these you
can write as linear programs all of the
constraint that I've given the the error
probability so on all of these can be
written as linear constraints and the
dual changes the min/max into the max
min or the other way around and it gives
you a more suitable formulation to prove
lower bounds now I'm afraid I would love
to give you intuition on how to use this
duel formulation of the of the partition
bound but I don't have a very good
intuition about it you what you want to
do is you want this beta of X Y is sort
of measuring the number of rectangles
and you're taking away something that
has to do with the correctness okay so
think of beta of X Y as 2 to the sea or
seize the communication bount that
you're trying to get and here well you
know it looks a little bit like a
discrepancy because you're looking at at
the measure of a rectangle in this like
it's not a distribution right so it's
not going to be something between 0 and
1 it's going to be something between
yeah so this is exactly this is the sum
of all the X wise in over all of the
inputs so again I'm neglecting a lot of
information like if you have a partial
function then this these sums get a
little bit change you have to be careful
about where the function is defined
where the function is not defined I'm
just doing it for total boolean
functions here
so what do you what would you like me to
so it's an optimization problem it's a
linear program and if you want to find
the partition bound for a function f you
need to find you need to find values so
you have variables alpha for every pair
of inputs X and why you need to find
values for input these the variables
beta for every x and y and then here are
some constraints for the alphas and the
betas that you've just proposed it has
to satisfy that for every rectangle the
sum of the beta is in that rectangle
minus the sum of the alphas in the so Z
is an input is an output of the function
so say Z equals zero so the zero part of
the rectangle when you sum all of the
alphas for that just a zero part of the
rectangle this should be close to one
this should be less than or equal to one
so you propose alpha and beta and and
then you and then you can do they're
just so alpha x wise are non-negative
reals betas can be negative this is
important and we'll see in a moment in
the last two minutes why ok so the
there's a difference of scale the
communication complexity is at least the
log of the partition bound the partition
bound is kind of measuring number of
rectangles so so this beta is going to
be something like the number of
rectangles all right and this is going
to be with respect to this this
weighting scheme beta the size of the
rectangle and the Alpha size of the be
part of the rectangle ok epsilon is the
error it's an error parameter so it's
how much if you want a lower bound on
the epsilon error communication
complexity irrespective of distribution
so that it can't be more than one right
uh yeah yeah yeah these numbers are big
they're going there ranging up to 2 to
the see more or less no we can be huge
it's it's different from the discrepancy
in the sense that discrepancy everything
is normalized you're talking about like
one day fun group tangle of size of size
one that if bad day is more than one
that it going to file this condition so
so the individual betas are going to be
okay they can be anything right legit
though this zero right so this kid this
is going to be 0 yeah bet I spout that
this see this makes it clear that they
smiled about the one for each individual
point yeah okay that's true I thought
you meant this this biz beta over
everything the beta over everything is
going to be due to see but locally it's
it's going to be how it's going to have
to be less than 1 ok so the relaxed
partition bound now I I told you what
the relaxed partition bound was in like
sort of the primal scheme and I told you
that it's a matter of the Equality
constraint being up so that the
efficiency being approximately equal for
all inputs and how does this translate
in the in the duel is you get this
constraint Alpha X Y minus beta X Y
positive so I'm running out of time so
let me cut to the chase how do we prove
that the relative discrepancy is always
less than the relaxed partition bound
well we take any solution to the relax
the relative discrepancy that is a
distribution new and a distribution row
and we show that we can come up with a
better solution to the relaxed partition
bound so I'm not going to bore you with
this change of variables but what's
important in this change of variables is
to notice these following two points so
the first is that the betta is playing
the is playing the role of row this
rescaling of the rectangles and new news
role is played by it again mu is is
normalized Rose normalized but alpha and
beta or not and they're scaled by this
factor 1 over Delta here which is one
over the discrepancy if you want to
think about it that okay so they're in a
different scale but alpha minus beta
corresponds to mu and beta corresponds
to row why am I telling you
because this plays an important role
when we want to really pin down what is
the you know how the relative
discrepancy compared compares to the
partition based methods so this is what
this change of variable shows is that we
can always find a better solution to the
relaxed partition bound from a solution
to the relative discrepancy if you can
change the distribution mu right if mu
is not fixed where things get
interesting interesting is that when the
distribution new is fixed well I told
you that the role of alpha was played by
new I mean alpha is just a scaled
version of the distribution mu so when
you want if you look at the at the
distributional version of the partition
bound this is exactly how it looks that
here we had alpha and now we have
instead of alpha defined on every x y
alpha is just like a scaling factor with
respect to MU right it's just a scalar
and it's multiplied always by mu so this
is the part that stays constant so this
change of variable is not going to go
through anymore which makes sense right
because it's not possible that it goes
through since we have a separation the
distributional case and I just showed
you that you could not have a separation
in the non distributional case and so
something has to fail in our proof and
this is where it fails because we're not
able to keep so we're not able to keep
alpha proportional to MU in the optimal
solution so let me just quickly go
through what happens in the in the fixed
distribution case so again I have my
partition bound remind I remind you that
this is the additional constraint that I
added so now I replaced alpha by alpha
mu so the scaled version of new now I
have less degrees of freedom now because
my alpha has to be proportional to MU to
go from the partition bound to the
relaxed partition bound this is the
constraint that I added so but let's
look about let's look at this sum this
row positive whether or not row has to
be positive I told you that
beta was proportional to ruin and my
change of variable here if Rose positive
then beta is going to be positive but in
the partition bound I don't have this
constraint that that beta has to be
positive beta can be positive or
negative so if I just add this
constraint that beta is positive I get
what we call the positive partition
bound so I take the partition bound I I
I force row to be positive or beta to be
positive depending on which of the
formulations you prefer and then you
know we just define for the sake of
completing the picture we take the
partition bound we add both additional
constraints and I get the week partition
bound okay so any guesses as to where
the relative discrepancy sits here
exactly it can't be because then it
would that would place it underneath of
the relaxed partition bound which would
place it underneath the information
complexity and we know that that's not
true so what's your second guess
so these constraints seem to be quite
important so if we look at the positive
partition bound in the week partition
bound the separation tells us that these
two so so the the bursting noise
function that we heard about yesterday
also separates these two because they
what they showed is that the relative
discrepancy is large and the information
complexity small the information
complexity is bigger than this so we
have a separation here an exponential
separation right so something something
funny is happening here with this
constraint yeah so if Rho is allowed to
be negative than it's the partition
bound yeah so it's kind of interesting
that your separation doesn't use ro- you
can make it negative but it's kind of
interesting that you don't because then
you know we have a little bit more
information about where this separation
is taking place for the separation you
only need this so it's a little bit
finer grain it implies that the
partition bound is large but it's kind
of interesting that this is what you use
so this is the picture for the the
distributional case this is the picture
for the non distributional case in fact
what happens is that these two collapse
for the district a non distributional
case so these two you can show for the
non distributional case that they
collapse which implies that it sits
below here the relax partition map so so
for me the interesting thing is to look
at you know what's happening here
exactly so since I'm more than running
out of time let me just summarize so
what we've given one of the
contributions is that we have a linear
program formulation which allows us to
compare it to the different lower bounds
that we're familiar with we we now know
that this this relative discrepancy is
the partition bound plus the added non
negativity constraint
the we know that when we we release the
distribution new then we do get a lower
bound on information complexity so we at
the moment we don't have a separation of
non distributional information
complexity and communication complexity
and another result which I haven't
spoken about so I think for me what's
most interesting now is to see if we can
get another separation baby at a higher
regime so that the talk yesterday the
bursting noise function the the
separation is for log n versus log log n
so log log and information complexity
and log on communication complexity can
this scale up sorry n is the size of the
input is that correct it's even worse
log log n versus log log log n it said
small they're talking about a very
little delicate little separation which
is not robust to for example additive
terms but maybe looking at this week
partition versus positive partition or
the partition versus the relaxed
partition maybe this is a first step
that we could do to try to change the
regime because now we're looking at
really one constraint of a linear
program maybe by focusing our attention
on on the impact of this this one
particular constraint will be able to
maybe give a simpler proof or maybe give
us something example or one and a higher
regime so they open problem is still
open is information complexity equal or
different from the communication
complexity in the non distributional
bound but but also the question of the
partition bound is still open is it
tight is there a separation between
complexity communication complexity and
partition bound both Kate in both cases
the answer would be interesting thank
you
other questions